[Music]  Justin Bieber could be in trouble with  the law again the Los Angeles County  Sheriff's Department confirmed e.t that  the 22 year old singer is being  investigated for an alleged head-butting  incident that took place at the Los  Angeles restaurant quote there is an  open investigation where someone inside  the establishment called and said that  something happened with him outside what  do you mean authorities have yet to  speak to the singer and police also tell  ET they haven't been able to confirm  Justin's involvement in the battery case  Bevers rep did not respond to requests  for comment and TMZ reports that Justin  allegedly head-butted a man at a  pre-grammy bash last weekend at Serafina  restaurant in LA this after he allegedly  got upset with a bystander who was  videotaping him and refused to delete  the video  you